[Music]
when i
first met sumail i knew this kid was
gonna be big
[Music]
he's as confident as he is controversial
money or the ego or the title title
what am i going to do with the title
i'll take the money indispensable
as he is infuriating this goes like oh
this guy didn't practice and you know
i'm just
i'm just taking this [ __ ] and i'm like
still taking it for four months i have
no [ __ ] issue with it
then he just doesn't stop you know like
someone keeps poking you in one point
you're gonna explode
tremendous as he is temperamental
[Applause]
regardless of what you may think of
sumail his talent is outright
indisputable he's the youngest
millionaire in the history of esports
and arguably the single greatest dota
player
of all time this
is his story
[Music]
it was in his native country of pakistan
when he was only eight years old
that syed sumail hassan had his first
encounter
with dota from that point on he was
determined
to become the best his ferocious work
ethic was shaped
not only by his upbringing but his
family's decision to immigrate to
illinois
in 2012. my dad worked really hard to
get me and my family here
i live with eight family members in a
small apartment and i share my room with
three family members
it's really mesmerizing for all of us
and he's been playing
so fast never tired never get bored
that same year sumail began to make a
name for himself
in the nel within two years he became
the in-house league's highest rated
player
and started getting offers to stand in
for professional teams
this is a lot of time waiting over the
mid lane there's your blink dude he's
going to catch him
oh one more clown so low he's able to
run
again now if samal says so
special delivery from mr sumail that was
sick
what a player long range zip while tping
that was impressive one such offer came
from sahil
universe aurora offlaner for north
america's flagship esports franchise
evil geniuses given their recent roster
troubles
it wasn't long before universe pushed
for sumail to join
himself fear ppd and the recently signed
aoi 2000. his desire to compete at the
highest level his
will to be a professional that was the
most prominent thing that i got from him
so when a spot opened up on evil
geniuses sumail was the first person
that we thought of
the spot in question was left by team
secret's drama-ridden acquisition of
ludwig zai wahlberg
and artur artesi babayev everyone
thought that we
were on the losing end of this western
shuffle as soon as we lost artesians eye
everyone would be like welcome to
becoming a tier 2 team again eg
artesi was not only a role model to
samael but
one of the only mid laners he thought
superseded him in skill
sumail had big shoes to fill and it
showed
his first lan the d2l finals in las
vegas
saw eg place third due in part to the
young mid laners
lackluster play very low on man or very
low on life arrow comes out he's dead
that's going to be your first blood omni
slash helping a clean house but look at
sumail just
absolutely melt now it's fear's turn
killing it down to about half out under
god's wrath and oh my goodness
god-like indeed and he is a vengeful
wrathful god an innocent little swap
ends in tears for the boys in blue
people started to wonder whether a
competitively inexperienced 15 year old
merited a spot on such a top tier team
then dac happened the 2015 dota 2
asia championships nicknamed mini ti on
account of its 3 million
prize pool was sumail's chance at
redemption
after going 11 and 4 in groups eg
climbed the upper bracket
and after losing to ti4 runner-up vici
gaming
managed to sweep their rivals team
secret in the lower bracket finals
s4 stuck in the middle of everybody gets
a personal call off calling blade will
not proc
however puppy going down to the split
shot of fear the double kill this is a
disaster secret
looks to be out of dac 2015
eg will find their way in the grand
finals best of five tomorrow versus
vichy gaming but it was in game three of
the grand finals against vichy gaming
where sumail put on what is quite
possibly the most fabled performance
of his career but things got off to a
rough start
moving on to sumail mid he's gonna get
caught out looks like vichy gaming are
up to it again
they'll start off with the shackles now
followed up with the double raise and
they've got the third if needed it's
not and they only got rougher
so sure still chasing but earth shaker
come into position now they're gonna
have a fissure is it in time one race
two rays
they get the kill again now they're
going to mid again looks like the shaman
is third time the charm as well well
first second were
sumail trying to run in dodge that last
race it's not gonna happen
fy and fenrir just wrecking sumail mid
there's gonna be a little pressure
towards the snake but rotating in though
is your earthshaker
and then just when sumail looked to be
out
he started to claw his way back in oh my
and they don't even get the deny super a
bit too quick now your hook shut in
from my size universe looking to turn it
he will end up falling
it's a one for one thus far fy going to
cancel a shackle super has a double
damage room though they have to be
careful
sumail running low on mata reyes is
coming out again they can't keep on
losing this
he clawed he's gonna find another kill
potentially on fy he does not
have the pole doesn't matter fy just
gonna get blown up
and clawed reflection do they actually
engage onto this the storm
zipping into the [ __ ] fighting nice ice
universe gonna bolt him could sue male
finish the job he drops that remnant
and clawed as a result looking good in
the top lane now black's gonna get
jumped with omnislash and the ball
lightning from some mail
a lot of players would crumble under
this kind of early pressure he's totally
back
four times in the lane and he's six and
five at minute nine
unbelievable until game three of the dac
finals
turned into the sumail show we go for
two is the real question they get the
hex up on universe
sumail zipping into the cogs but they
have no lock down that zoo salty coming
out
massive damage now the omni slash black
gonna get blown up it's three dead for
vichy
they're in danger here super needs to
turn it he tries to go into universe
blade fury working him into black hole
it's gonna be five eg again
out maneuvering vg gaming in the clutch
a triple for sumail
it worked once can it work a second time
super just barely caught by the black
hole
they're looking to wipe them all the
witch stocks are gonna get run down by
your store
and they've still got a pull left for
super he walks in
he wants to at least get racks out of
this he'll get nothing pulled back
wiped at the base a triple for zuma
dieback after dieback beachy gaming and
shambles
it's a 3-0 eg just won
over 1.3 million dollars
four days before his 16th birthday
sumail had won the third largest
tournament
in the history of esports people were
already starting to consider him the
best mid laner in the world
and as far as he was concerned they were
right
it was from this point on that
confidence and sheer
unadulterated aggression became sumail's
signature traits
now with the premier tournament win
under his belt it was time for sumail's
real test
the international eg entered the
tournament as favorites
alongside their rivals a team who'd won
four of their last five lands
team secret secret weren't just good
they were being hailed as quite possibly
the greatest lineup
of all time you say all-star team okay
there are 107 players
that have played 100 or more dota 2
matches
the top four winning percentages in that
group of players
are all on teams but it wasn't secret
whose elimination early on in the lower
bracket earned them a humiliating 7th
8th finish
that stonewalled eg in ti5's upper
bracket final
it was the unknown wildcard qualifying
incomprehensibly dominant
cdec ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
winners bracket final here
between cd ec gaming and evil geniuses
both teams
one series away from finding their spot
there into the grand
final look how quickly it bounced
there's nothing that eeg could do cdc's
physical damage output is ridiculous
they've got the vision of the bbd here
with the track out as well pvd in
trouble
they'll get themselves a fourth kill
some male the only last man standing
there for each
is that it that's it 20 minutes in
cdec they're into the ground finals
they've
done it after getting two owed by cdec
eg needed to lick their wounds they
started by conducting a sweep of their
own against lgd
in the lower bracket finals
he's gonna drop next maybe he could
additionally join him
as yao does what he get against the male
it's not quite enough now that he heals
him again
where's that stun they get it and he's
down nine finished he's out
he's out for 63 seconds with no gyro for
110
a.g have done it they have taken game
one here
against lgd they don't have the echo the
shadow beam bought out before the fight
he's gonna go on mmo right now no time
to think about it mmy getting nuked to
smithereens
he frantically retreats he will survive
for now
university of fishing for a host but he
doesn't need the kill he's got the rats
and now he's gonna get him anyway
and eg will move
eg had made it all the way to the grand
finals
but victory was anything but certain
cdec
were less experienced and less
accomplished than eg
but they had developed a hyper
aggressive play that no team at the
tournament
had been able to crack but eg had
studied cdec
and planned to be the first team to
survive their assault
turn around he is dead where's your five
back here she comes the t beats the t1
towers
two heroes down already this could be it
the money will let
eg win this fight they kind of want it
anyway with the amount of damage the
fear has stormed
jumping all the way back up again they
find aggressive
queen of pain the only one up they fell
at the last time but it was
eg will take game one in the ti fight
grand final
from what looked like an unstoppable cdc
through ingenious drafting and
disciplined play eg took game one
but it was in game three where after
suffering a loss in game two
eg hit their stride they find their
opening it's the lying and down
q also being thrown down by that
concussive shot locked inside the cops
in the middle of the river he needs a
path to freedom it just doesn't exist a
smell he even goes in deeper
on the back of chickie the sun will be
available they back it back in they're
still the defensive spirits of marvel's
fighter fence
and maybe there is enough damage
aggressive siri chain now they need the
damage
forced out the way aggressive goes to
them
trying to run himself out of the cops
five stops and this is real trouble
right now for tina
down in the tree line as well there are
no buybacks available
[Applause]
on the back of sumail's ember spirit eg
had taken control of the series
by game four it was too late sumail's
storm spirit had been given
free reign the nail in cdec's coffin
came in the form of
one final play one of the greatest in ti
history
the six million dollar echo slam
there is no hook shot they're all
together ppd here comes the ice blast
ready for the dog
[Applause]
about 10 minutes later sumail became the
youngest player
ever to win a ti he'd been a
professional player for nine months
and was already the youngest millionaire
in the history of esports
and the sixth highest earning player of
all time
sumail hadn't just reached the top he'd
done it faster than anyone thought
possible
[Music]
in the wake of their hard-earned victory
at ti eg
made a controversial roster change we
ended up releasing aui
and bringing in our old teammate artesi
to play with us
and um it's just kind of what
everyone on our team thought was best
for us going into this next year
ironically artesi's prodigal return to
eg resulted in six months of second and
third place finishes
the general consensus was that the
reason for eg's downfall
was twofold from a compositional
perspective artesi's farm intensity
had relegated samael to the role of
spacemaker
from a cosmological one eg had gone a
step too far in kicking aoi
and now from a karmic standpoint they
had to pay for it
things got so bad that come the manila
major artesi had once again left eg
for secret and this time he'd taken
universe with him
universe rejoined eg shortly after but
the situation was clear
eg were coming apart at the seams but
sumail
stayed the course as did ppd eg's
hard-nosed captain and drafter
they had become the pillars of eg the
brains and the brawn respectively
and despite their somewhat tenuous
relationship come
ti-6 that stability showed in their
upper bracket series against
e-home eg not only became the first team
in the history of ti's main stage to
come back against mega creeps
but prove victorious in what is
canonically regarded
as one of the greatest games of dota
ever played
what are they looking for the initiation
comes out of fear repressor activated by
old eleven not gonna give the chance for
a second private roar he's gonna get
blown up inside the chronosphere
he's down and now evil geniuses still
five up but here comes that obvious
slash bouncing around there shattered
even hoping to be able to go on inside
but an arrow
oh my god the male just nailed them but
he still managed to get himself away in
the back lights
the spaceless void though in the back
here he's now gonna go for all the
chickens now
they be activated and now he's gonna run
himself away universe center he's back
eg might be able to do this they're
holding
somehow hard to go another fan rear no
chaotic off bringing the eyes to dragons
first
he'll take him out he holds back down
[Applause]
but eg just didn't have the grit to go
all the way
and despite clawing tooth and nail
against digital chaos
sumail misses chance to play for a
second ti title
and we are straight for the jugular on
to the throw but they stop renzo
they hold for now fears coming out with
the vengeance
oh my god that defeat was enough to send
eg
into disarray artesi returned to the
team for the third
and final time as fear retired to become
the team's coach
more surprising however was ppd's
decision to leave the roster
and become eg's ceo there was something
about ppd sudden and haphazard departure
that didn't quite sit right
but it would be almost a year before the
truth came to light
after ti6 the plan was not for me to be
the ceo
that was not the initial plan it just
kind of changed
into that you know we had to talk after
ti and it was
hey what are we going to do we're in the
middle of this huge divestment where
we're all taking ownership in eg
and it was oh and all of a sudden like
sumail didn't want to play with me
because i i'm a tough i'm a tough guy
i'm a strong personality and
when people aren't when i feel like
people aren't giving it they're all
that's that's when i you know that's my
biggest pet peeve that's when i actually
get frustrated
at 16 sumail had arguably become the
greatest player
in the history of dota by 17 he becomes
something of a superstar
both in and outside the game and yet
as far as sumail was concerned his
greatness wasn't up for debate
in his eyes he was the best and always
would be
i wouldn't say i'm an arrogant person
but when it comes to the game
i like to be cocky so i mean i talk [ __ ]
then i prove myself
i mean as long as i'm performing like i
don't care if people hate me
i shouldn't be like a nice guy who needs
to be loved by everyone
and yeah that's pretty much it
when it was announced after ti6 that
crit a first-time drafter
was being brought in as ppd's
replacement the community was skeptical
sumail was developing a reputation for
being haughty and self-absorbed
and it wasn't clear that he'd be able to
stay on top without ppd there
to keep him in check you're probably one
of the best if not the best mid in the
world who gave you the most trouble in
this tournament
as the enemy mid i will try to be humble
but i will say no one
like no one not the no one but no one oh
okay
eg spent the next season trying to
regain the sense of stability they'd
lost
everything was in place to give crit the
start he needed to hit the ground
running
as the team's new captain but the danish
drafter
never broke out the way he was supposed
to eg put up decent results
including a third fourth place finish at
the boston major
but were never truly dominant by the
time they were earning
yet another third fourth place finish at
the kiev major
the player's patience was starting to
wear thin
heroes are good versus monkey king as
well as um very active
ooh universe really not feeling that was
a lot of good emotion that was most
emotion i've ever seen from universe i
think
he's really not sure about his draft
right now but sumail never stopped
showing flashes of brilliance
and even though they went on to win the
manila masters and take second place at
epicenter
it was at ti7 that eg's cracks became
full-blown holes
despite going 11-5 in the groups eg were
swept out of the upper brackets first
round by eventual runner-up's
newbie until he tries to get the jump he
found the black hole
it is on to kp so there you have the
damage to finish him off side comes in
with the airplane
he managed to save him there's the
second of black hole the universe is
down
they've lost two sonic wave flies
through from s triple c
triple
[Applause]
having squandered their upper bracket
birth eg were once again swept in the
first round of the lower bracket
this time by team empire and despite
putting up a truly
formidable performance on puck sumail
had to stand by and watch as his team's
ti hopes
came to a disastrous end eg
it's over for them eg was so close to
stabilizing so many times
fought their hearts out in the last
match but it wasn't enough
falling 0-2 devastation for evil
geniuses
the team's efforts to rebuild a dominant
roster around sumail
had failed and it was clear that
something needed to change
what wasn't clear was whether the
problem was sumail
or his teammates
shortly after eg's catastrophic showing
at ti7
zai left the team and fear rejoined eg
in an attempt to restore some much
needed leadership
sumail's record had never been spotless
but from then on the sumail-centric
nature of eg
became a scapegoat on which to blame not
only the loss of ppd
but the downfall of eg as a whole and
after
three months of abysmal results eg did
the unthinkable
universe who'd been on eg for nearly
five years
and who was reputed for being one of the
most stable offlaners in the history of
competitive dota
had been kicked so you guys are it's not
like any hard feelings or anything you
guys are still
you know cool just mutual kind of like
changing of the team or
i think you're cool i was uh uh
i talked to universe like not very
briefly but
yeah i didn't like uh see anything bad
from him i think i i mean universe is
like you know he's a very
cool god-headed guy so he won't like
take he he won't hold grudges in my
opinion like that's how i see it
crit moved to position four as misery
was recruited to be the team's new
captain
and to everyone's shock fear became eg's
new mid laner
sumail in an effort to regain some sense
of positional dominance
had switched to the offlane if eg's
decision to kick ppd
had become retroactively recognized as
the beginning of the end for sumail
then his decision to leave the mid lane
altogether was the end
in itself once ppd chimed in
he and sumail both became rotating
targets in a community-wide
witch hunt then he comes out and do do
this interview while i'm not saying
anything he's goes like oh this guy
didn't practice and you know i'm just
i'm just taking his [ __ ] and i'm like
still taking it for four months i have
no [ __ ] issue with it
then he just doesn't stop you know like
someone keeps poking you in one point
you're gonna explode
if i if i were that bad of a player if i
were like i had no right respect for the
game i don't think
every other player on the team who had
played with him like for more
like then they had played for me like
for more time they would have decided to
play around them you know
but it didn't work out that way so i
guess sometimes you just gotta accept
the fact
that you're wrong and just [ __ ] move
on by the start of 2018
eg's performance had truly plummeted
sumail's offlane stint wasn't paying off
having instead subjected him to a
barrage of criticism
and worse yet ridicule finally
midway through eg's middling performance
at esl genting sumail
snapped sumail had reached his breaking
point
from here on out he became likened to
something of a plummeting pop star
a prodigy whose prolonged infantility
stemmed from his having achieved
greatness too quickly for his own good
after finishing 10th 12th at esl
birmingham
gigi kicked misery and fear it wasn't
until
eg announced that they'd poached reputed
captain an offlaner fly
and s4 from og that people had reason to
think that sumail
might once again reach the top the king
of the mid lane
was back
[Music]
samil what's your motivation money money
yeah definitely
everyone else is going to tell you
they're playing because they're super
passionate yeah they love the game
yeah no i mean that's the good thing
right like i'm the best at it
but i can also make money out of it so
it's just a bonus if you had to pick one
money or the ego or the title title
what am i going to do with the title
i'll take the money
even after eg qualified for ti-8 and
took first place at the summit eight
people were skeptical that this new og
inflected eg
would be able to perform after finishing
the groups with an affirming 13-3 record
eg swept secret in the first round of
the upper bracket
it wasn't until they met ogie who were
seeking revenge for the
unforgivable blow that was s4 and fly's
departure
that eg met their match the rx jumps in
looks for the fisher gets started
cancels the black hole but the combo
from thompson straight on top of rtg
takes him out
rtz is dead for 80 seconds s4 crit and
fly getting pushed back to the base
you can see how confident they are they
know they can clean this out there's the
last fight for eg they jump forward
rolls in but immediately the ghost
jarricks in again with the control the
fish are out between the two of them
they
find the spirit they're going to find
this for they're going to find fly
as well after trading evenly in games 1
and 2
eg entered an extraordinarily
anticipated game 3
with their upper bracket lives at stake
sumail needed to put on the performance
of a lifetime
so he did pretty slow yep
unfortunately his 31 and 4 stat line
wasn't enough against every odd og
won their series against eg and
eventually the international altogether
given the unprecedented and historic
nature of og's run
much of what made eg's own run so
impressive ended up being overshadowed
eg went on to beat virtus pro the
highest ranked dota team on the planet
as well as team liquid the second
highest and winners of ti7
you and i talked in our interview
earlier this week about
what it would mean to you to win ti for
the second time you are now that much
closer to it
how does it feel now uh before this ti i
was just uh
i was trying to play to showcase as a
best player but
i don't think that's the case anymore
i'm just like
i'm just trying to have i'm trying to
have fun
i've i want to have the best team it
doesn't matter who the best player is
anymore that's how i see it
it's a team game and i think we have a
really good chance to win because
the team is really looking good
lgd smell blood they're going in maybe
pressing forward
eg last heroes left alive it's a blade
mill from artesi trying to stem the
bleeding but it's not happening another
in the grave
eg all out of focus in trouble and
inside their base this is looking like
it's going to be it is sumail
last one alive for the team dead again
and gg
lgd are moving on to the grand finals
going into ti8 eg were ranked 11th
and were 11 000 points out of first
in what was arguably the most
competitive ti of all time
they finished third and boy did they
earn it
sumail finished the international 8
having averaged the second most fantasy
points of any player
with no one else from eg even making it
into the top
25. he declared his return to the mid
lane
to be the return of its king and despite
the fact that in doing so
he'd invoked a community-wide eye roll
his performance at ti-8
had been nothing short of regal sumail
once again emerged from an international
as quite possibly the best mid laner in
the world even though he missed yet
another chance to play for a second ti
something that hadn't been true for a
long time was made resoundingly clear
whatever the cause of eg's shortcomings
was whatever had kept them from going
all the way at
ti it most definitely wasn't sumail
ultimately whether you love or hate
sumail it isn't because he thinks he's
the best
it isn't even because of his arrogance
his irreverence
or the drama he incites it's because
in spite of all those things he's
probably right
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button